corse france toute une histoire
documentaire en deux parties qui nous
rappelle dans le détail toutes les
étapes majeures qui ont construit ou
déconstruit ce lien si complexes entre
lille et l'état français pendant plus de
deux siècles et demi un film qui a aussi
un parti pris celui de dire que la corse
aurait été délaissées parfois malmenée
et même sacrifié par par paris alors
est-ce un peu vrai est ce un peu faux
quelles nuances apportées à cette thèse
voyons cela avec nos invités sur ce
plateau jean félix acquaviva bienvenus
vous êtes député de haute corse vous
faites partie des trois élus
nationalistes qui sont entrés pour la
première fois à l'assemblée nationale en
2017 vous venez d'être réélu comme vos
deux collègues michel delpech bienvenue
à vous également vous étiez préfet de la
corse du sud en 2006 et 2007 puis vous
avez été directeur de cabinet de la
ministre de l'intérieur michèle
alliot-marie et vous êtes aujourd'hui
conseiller d'état jacques follorou
bienvenus vous êtes journaliste au mans
vous venez de publier le livre mafia
corse une île sous influence aux
éditions robert laffont c'est votre
quatrième ouvrage sur la corse dans
celui ci vous vous êtes intéressé aux
relations entre élus et mafieux van
damme astor bienvenue à vous également
vous êtes constitutionnaliste et
professeur de droit public à
l'université de toulouse capitole vous
avez récemment publié cet essai vers
l'autonomie pour une évolution
institutionnelle de la corse chez
albiana merci infiniment à tous les
quatre et d'être d'être ici je voudrais
qu'on revient d'abord sur vos
impressions à tous sur ce documentaire
que l'on vient voir et sur ce parti pris
dont je parlais à l'instant
historiquement la corse est elle un
territoire qui a été oublié maltraité
abandonné comme le disent beaucoup
d'intervenants dans ce documentaire jean
félix et écouter ce ne serait pas
surpris d'un temps de 2 ma voix que
effectivement ceux de kant est assez
fidèle à ce qu'on entend par l'essor de
la corse je ne suis pas adepte du noir
ou du blanc quand on regarde des
sociétés aux quand on regarde des
communautés humaines ni des relations
entre comme si humaine et culturelle un
peuple comme look là que les corses et
un état central néanmoins je reconnaisse
le commentaire l'idée de repasser de
revisiter l'ensemble des grands
événements qui ont marqué l'histoire des
relations et compris de manière durable
quand on parle de loi douanière quand on
parle de la guerre de 14
quand on parle est compris entre la
conquête militaire et ses suites du
mouvement militaire ou delà de
l'intégration par la francisation du
parma pauli 1-3 ce sont des faits
historiques de développer ces faits
historiques et n'empêche pas d'avoir des
regards critiques évidemment sur la
société mais en tout cas permet de poser
les choses enfin un léger haro sur
l'état français dans ce documentaire je
parlais parti pris est ce que vous le
partagez michel delpech ou est ce que
c'est un haro sur l'état français un peu
facile alors moi j'ai trouvé que ce ce
documentaire en deux temps était plutôt
bien structuré avec un premier temps
sous le vocable intégration si je me
souviens bien et qui donc marc comment
l'ancrage de la corse dans notre pays et
surtout dans la république et puis le
deuxième 2 le deuxième temps sous le
vocable contestation relate finalement
la période la plus récente on va dire
les 60 dernières années à peu près
date très importante
58 1962 on le voit bien et quand on
parle de décalage économique et social
c'est vrai qu'il était particulièrement
fort de ce temps là bientôt 70 ans j'ai
souvenir d'un frère aîné étant allés en
vacances en corse à la fin des années 60
quand il revenait parmi nous y décrivait
à un territoire et une société qui était
éloignée de la nôtre quand bien même je
suis originaire d'un tout petit
département rural le cantal donc cette
réalité est hélas et ensuite mon n'y
reviendra sans doute ses relations très
très compliquées entre
l'état le gouvernement et lille dans la
diversité de ses composantes mais je
pense ça sera au coeur du débat
sur tout cela bien sûr jacques follorou
vous le partagez vous cette ce qu'on
ressent dans ce documentaire qui est que
la corse finalement n'aurait pas été
considéré comme un territoire français à
part entière sur le fait que la corse a
été soit resté à l'écart la
redistribution de la richesse à l'écart
des trente glorieuses et c'est ça
honnêtement c'est un instant fait acquis
qui explique aussi en partie l'émergence
du mouvement autonomiste et nationaliste
et puis histoire politique de la corse
l'histoire de la relation aussi qui
relie qui nous ramène à la relation
entre l'état et la corse aujourd'hui me
semble oublier un pan entier de ce qui
me semble aujourd'hui plombée
considérablement ce territoire c'est que
dans ce dialogue obsessionnelle j'en
avais de dire exclusif entre l'état et
le mouvement nationalistes et
autonomistes qui aujourd'hui est aux
manettes depuis sept ans en cause je
pense qu'on peut aujourd'hui avoir un
regard un droit d'un pain parler de
droit d'inventaire à leur égard je pense
que dans ce dialogue un peu obsessionnel
ils ont oublié qu'ils avaient que ce que
ce même directeur de la république était
soustrait à l'autorité de l'état et
finalement soustrait aux idéaux portés
par les nationalistes et autonomistes et
qu'aujourd'hui qui s'appelle la un
pouvoir parallèle un pouvoir occulte et
inquiète un système pesant moins mafieux
et qui ont fait l'objet du livre visés
en début sur la société connaît et si on
s'intéresse et là c'est pas simplement
s'intéresser aux fins criminelles
s'intéresser à l'avenir de cette société
de ce territoire et c'est bien sûr on y
viendra ses premiers mais j'aurai
terminé quand même ce tour de table sur
votre avis à vous sur le documentaire
que l'on a tous vus ensemble van damme
astor à un moment donné gilles simeoni
dans le film nous parle du sentiment
d'injustice et d'iniquité que son père
et son oncle ont ressenti en arrivant à
marseille au moment de leurs études et
il se rend compte que la vie sur le
continent et la façon dont sont lotis
les continentaux n'est pas la même que
celle des corses est ce que vous l'avez
ressenti vous voulez partager je les ai
vécu j'ai été également étudiante à aix
en provence après avoir passé 19 ans en
corse mais je reviens moi aussi si on
voulait bien sûr le documentaire je
trouve qu'ils mais pour en revenir à
votre question particulièrement bien en
évidence le fait que l'histoire de la
corse est l'histoire d'une soumission
sans cesse courageuse et on le voit bien
et deux volets du documentaire c'est à
dire ce qui n'apparaît pas c'est que la
france la corse a toujours subi des
agressions territoriale et ça commence à
gueuler chardin et romain les vandales
les autorités pontificale lombard de
byzantine et sarrazin donc ça vient de
loin et que sans cesse il a été beaucoup
dit notamment dans le volet 1 les corps
sont
on pose est quand même une résistance
courageuse et l'agression était de deux
ordres militaires ça a été souvent dit
en rappelant la lourdeur des pertes au
sein d'une population à ces petites
finalement et juridique un e juriste par
la loi sur les douanes hier qu'ils
étaient totalement des lois actions qui
ont forgé une inégalité absolument
abominable qui ont perduré tout le long
du 19e siècle je parle même pas des lois
sur sur la langue corse donc ça c'est
important et je finis juste parce que
c'est à mon avis l'un des plus beaux
discours qu'ils aient pu être prononcée
sur la corse par pour revenir à ma
soumission courageuse quand l'accord se
libère après la seconde guerre mondiale
quand de gaulle vient faire son célèbre
discours place du diamant il a une
phrase extraordinaire il vous auriez pu
attendre vous alliez être liberté mais
vous vouliez de vos propres vainqueur
voilà et j'aime bien que les
documentaires mettre ça en avant oui on
a subi subi subi mais quand même cette
résistance pour un si petit malheur
c'est intéressant vous parlez de
résistance armée d'agression ce que ce
documentaire ne dit pas trop ou
minimisent peut-être un peu vous allez
me le dire ou pas jean félix acquaviva
sont aussi peut-être la responsabilité
des corses dans la dimension crapuleuses
qui est existante ou pas sur les écoutes
et qu'il existe une grimace yeux savez
moi j'étais militant sioniste depuis le
début puis j'ai l'âge de 14 15 ans je me
rappelle avoir manifesté en 1991
à verre avec des mouvements
nationalistes exclusivement nationales
d'ailleurs à ce moment là c'est pas une
opposition contre les autres nous étions
six ans dans la rue autour du thème
mafia nos donc l'émergence de
l'autonomisme et du nationalisme en
corse va de pair avec les luttes
écologiques les luttes démocratiques
contre la fraude électorale parce que ça
n'oublie que c'est aussi en réaction à
certains bastions clanique que naissent
ces mouvements là et puis aussi contre
les dérives autour de logique de
surprofits de sur rampe sur certains
secteurs accaparée par certains certains
certaines bandes de certaine logique ça
n'existe pas que depuis quelques années
je veux dire cette dérive existe je
parle 87 ali a 31 ans et on pourra
revenir sur les politiques pénales de
justice de police depuis 31 ans voire
depuis 40 ans dans les responsabilités
de pourquoi en attaque et les uns et pas
les autres en termes judiciaires j'ouvre
une parenthèse pour l'enfermer aussi tôt
pour dire qu'encore une fois nous sommes
là pour regarder devant et effectivement
que je fais partie d'un mouvement qui
n'est au centre et ce n'est pas simple
l'éthique démocratie la morale politique
comme un élément important de
construction d'une responsabilité corse
parce que le combat pour l'autonomie des
décisions va de pair avec l'autonomie et
la responsabilisation au sein de la
société corse et c'est ce pourquoi
d'ailleurs nous avons obtenu la majorité
absolue avec gilles simeoni parce que ce
discours laquelle les secours
fondamental durant la campagne de 2021
et il faut fonder des relations
politiques et des actions à l'échelle de
la collectivité là dessus mais il faut
aussi qu'ils aient un partenariat réel
avec l'état à l'aune de ce que l'on
regarde son documentaire il est plus que
temps notre avis pour poser les choses
de manière sereine et tranquille et les
partenaires sans jus kapisa et ont-ils
été là dans l'histoire michel delpech ce
que ce documentaire semble un peu aux
maîtres ce sont aussi les règlements de
comptes l'éclat stickage les violences
qui sont là aussi factuelles sur l'île
l'état latine tous les partenaires
encore je veux préciser que ce jour ce
soir je m'exprime à titre personnel
mandaté par par personne et uniquement
au vu de mon expérience et en dix ans de
suite que je fais partie de ceux des
serviteurs de l'état qui ont été
affectés en corse à deux reprises à
j'étais en 84 86 comme secrétaire
général de la préfecture à ajaccio puis
j'étais en 2006 2007 comme préfet de
corse donc à vingt ans d'intervalle
effet tu fais partie de ceux qui disent
oui j'aime la corse mais une fois qu'on
a dit ça il faut ouvrir les yeux sur
d'autres réalités qui sont quand même
oublié par le documentaire sa deuxième
piquet bonjour voix 2 la première mal
vient d'être évoqué tout à l'heure c'est
tout ce qui touche les phénomènes de
violence de banditisme de raquette de
crapulerie je sais pas si on peut aller
jusqu'aux mots de mafia moi je le
mettrais avec un s parce que c'est
plutôt des plusieurs groupes ici ou là
sur des territoires etc mais c'est une
réalité et la violence pardonnez-moi
cantonais préfet
c'est claude erignac assassiné et je
veux le dire avec avec force avec
profondeur et avec une pensée pour son
épouse et ses enfants je ne me suis
jamais senti menacé jamais mon
tempérament sans doute me protège
j'étais entouré toujours officier de
sécurité la consigne qui m'avait été
donnée c'était surtout garder les autour
de vous ou michele que j'ai fait et ce
volet quand même violence et c est une
réalité qui
qui perturbe kick ass beaucoup de
projets et ça c'est le deuxième volet si
vous voulez on a du mal à faire avancer
les bons dossiers les beaux projets et
on voit sur la route se mêler des
oppositions des contestations parfois
parfaitement justifiée mais d'autres
plus plus secrètes je vais vous citer un
seul exemple qui restaient dans ma
mémoire donc moi j'avais porté le
deuxième volet du plan exceptionnel
programme exceptionnel d'investissement
le pays j'avais signé là l'engagement de
plus de 1 milliard d'euros ce qui était
une fierté bien sûr bien sûr mais quand
vous voyez sur le chantier c'était jeu
le chantier de la déviation de bocognano
en blé matic une nuit quatre engins de
travaux publics qui sont explosés d'une
entreprise insulaire vous dit quand même
quand même et ça qu'est ce que c'est
derrière des règlements de compte les
règlements de comptes mais mafieux
crapuleux et donc vous fait perdre du
temps à la corse vous avez à l'encontre
de ses intérêts vous allez à l'encontre
du développement donc je crois que ce
deuxième volet c'est une priorité que
doivent partager les représentants de
l'état les élus qui ne met pas du tout
en cause la volonté d'aller en ce sens
mais ça me paraît crucial thème du
développement on va essayer de
comprendre ce qu'est ce nationalisme en
corse à quel moment il apparaît qu'elle
a été le tournoi et pour cela je
voudrais qu'on écoute ce qu'on dit dans
le documentaire le politiste andria fazi
d'un chien la radicalisation du
mouvement régionaliste sa transformation
en nationalisme intervient en 1973 tu
fait multiples erreurs commises par le
gouvernement le refus d'ouvrir
l'université
le refus d'autoriser d'enseignement
facultatif de la langue corse qui était
possible pour le breton le basque depuis
l'inaction face aux déchets chimiques de
la société montedison donc là on voit
c'était pâques en 1973 d'un côté des
mouvements régionalistes qui disent
devenir autonomiste on voit pour la
première fois peut-être lecarme de
nationalisme notamment des années
tauriel de maxime eogn en août 1973 je
suis nationaliste corse menace toft à ce
moment là qu'apparaît le nationalisme le
tournant c'est 73 et que veut dire
précisément nationalisme accord enfin ça
c'est une excellente question parce que
pas plus tard qu'il ya au parlement
européen nous en avons parlé nous
n'étions pas d'accord parce que c'est un
mot qui gêne beaucoup c'est vrai les les
continentaux et les européens et qui
fait encore débat je pense qu'il
faudrait peut-être que notamment on amis
et collègues en tant que politis
réfléchi sur ce terme mais c'est vrai la
contestation en fait elle commence pas
là le documentaire ne montrait bien en
réalité le premier grand marasme c'est
après la première guerre mondiale et
c'est là où notamment amour vrac et un
mot un journal commence à mettre en
avant cette idée d'autonomie moquez pas
du tout nouvel le premier volet montre
même ans pascal parle il revient après
le premier exil il entend encore créer
une autonomie donc c'est vrai que le mot
aujourd'hui c'est enfin moi j'essaie
d'expliquer ainsi aux journalistes ou
aux étudiants les nationales la grande
famille des nationalistes se divise
aujourd'hui essentiellement en autonomie
et en indépendantistes et on a choisi ce
terme générique autonomie indépendance
c'est pas tout avoir d'un point de vue
juridique n'avoir dans le volet 2
d'ailleurs le volet 2 commence par une
interview de edmond signé en 1973 et
regarder pour vous dire c'est pas une
revendication nouvelle il dit la chose
suivante je suis pour une autonomie
interne je le cite parker and de mémoire
ce qui exclut le séparatisme ni mes
affaires étrangères ni la défense
nationale mais tout le reste nous
voulons voter nos propres lois points je
pourrais pas en tant que
constitutionnelles et en 2022 donner
meilleur défi wind en moi je me ferais
je trouve que la distinction entre
autonomistes et nationaliste la haye les
particuliers pertinente maintenant à
l'aune de la foi de ski c'est ce qui a
été rappelé à l'instant par le député à
quoi vivent sur le fait qu'il ya une
victoire politique des autonomistes qui
se sont qui ont défait la coalition avec
les nationalistes ils ont vu ils ont
avec les indépendants que les
indépendants disparaît ils ont gagné
super ils ont ils ont gagné seul et
c'était pas et c'était pas gagné et je
pense que même il faut il faut lire en
tout cas c'est en tant que journaliste
comme ça je le lis tout l'épisode yvan
colonnes et c'est moi me semble être
avant tout doit être lue
à allonnes deux sets de 7 de ce combat
politique entre nationalistes et
autonomistes et avec un parent avec un
paradoxe formidable c'est à dire qu'un
personnage yvan colonna qualité qui est
détesté qui était détesté par le
mouvement nationaliste historique depuis
le début parce que c'était un militant
nationaliste qui n'assumait pas
politiquement son acte qui alors que ses
camarades ses frères de sang ses frères
d'armes plutôt
pierre alessandri alain ferrandi assumer
devant la justice avoir commis cet acte
au nom d'un idéal au nom d'une idée yvan
colonna
était un leurre un compagnon d'armes
refusé d'assumer ça et pour le mouvement
nationaliste et nationales historiques
c'était inacceptable et on a vu c'est là
où j'en viens au paradoxe c'est qu'on a
vu lycée même nationaliste faire du même
yvan colonna un étendard d'une
contestation sur une gouvernance
aujourd'hui politique etc mais
aujourd'hui la vous avez raison
d'insister sûr ce point aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il ya des inquiétudes sur un
éventuel un une émergence un retour
d'une rive d'une rivalité forte entre
les deux courants voir s'exprimer entre
us entre autonomistes et
indépendantistes
savez moi je crois que le terme
autonomie est très clair vous l'avez dit
c'est décidé dans sa tombe de règles
spécifiques un territoire parce que ces
règles permettraient de faire avancer ce
territoire je vous rappelle que le
statut d'autonomie reconnu certains
territoires dans la constitution
française la polynésie saint martin
saint barthélémy où ce sont les doter du
statut dit d'autonomie le mouvement est
rentré dans la constitution 2008 lors de
la réforme constitutionnelle de nicolas
sarkozy et donc il ya des des modèles au
sein de constitution française comme il
y en a dans les îles méditerranéennes la
sardaigne comme une année aux açores et
ce sont nos références de travail bien
là dessus il faut quand même considérer
que nous avons eu une réaction
intellectuelle et de positionnement
pôles politiques violentes de la part de
l'état à la mesure que nous gagnons les
scrutins
ça veut dire que nous avons été
confronté à une rigueur centraliste
covin très forte depuis 2010 est alors
que nous avions contribué à l'arrêt de
la violence clandestine puisque c'est la
société corse elle même c'est la société
corse elle même et non pas un pouvoir
extérieur qui a essayé de faire
comprendre qu'il fallait arrêter les
voix de lutte clandestine armée pour
lutter contre la spéculation foncière
immobilière et malgré tout trois fois
nous allions aux élections territoriales
avec une majorité absolue
ensemble ou séparés c'est ce que veut
dire jacques follorou et malgré tout
nous avons eu en face de nous un
interlocuteur qui ont béziers 15 et vous
vos biaisé donc vos questions ne sont
pas de vraies questions il ya des lignes
rouges y compris sur l'autonomie moi je
me suis entendue voire à un ministre
qu'il a mais l'autonomie vous voulez
vous que le tlm est alors c'est
l'indépendance jamais trouvé l'autonomie
c'est l'auto lieu au sein réplique
français ce n'est pas l'autonomie au
sein de république intergalactique de
quoi parlons temps soyons un peu honnête
intellectuellement et là on touche
vraiment lorsqu'on prend la démarche
démocratique sert le verdict des urnes
un problème profondément
culturel qui est lié à la construction
de répliques française
la revue française s'est construite
contre des territoires interne c'est la
seul pays qui s'est construit contre la
bretagne contre la corse par la conquête
militaire etc il ya une idéologie
dans ses recherches et certains
interlocuteurs pas tous fort
heureusement nous sommes des gens de
dialogue et nous sommes là pour discuter
que les gens de bonne volonté mais
cherche certains étaient locuteurs de
l'eau de l'autre fonction publique
d'état ou de certains mystères c'est de
l'ordre du religieux c'est à dire que
vous pouvez gagner les élections mille
fois vous pouvez étayer mille fois que
l'autonomie permettra de changer ou de
réguler le prix de carburants de lutter
comme pré spéculation foncière et
garantir le droit au logement ce que
nous sommes en mesure de montrer
ça sera pas un sujet et ça c'est le vrai
danger des relations aujourd'hui c'est à
dire rester dans ce dossier dans ce
miroir là ne pas s'entendre et ses
danseuses poison là parce que ça ça fera
des deux futurs conflits et nous ne
voulons pas et pourtant pardonnez moi
vous pouvez pas nier qu'il y ait eu des
évolutions institutionnelles de vraie
évolution institutionnelle s'est
rappelée dans le film le film rappelle
que lorsque françois mitterrand arrive
au pouvoir en 81 des gestes concrets
sont faits par l'état il écrit un
nouveau statut pour lille avec une
assemblée de corse sous l'égide de
gaston defferre dix ans plus tard en 91
deuxième étape avec pierre joxe qui fait
encore évoluer le statut de l'île est
lui même nous explique pourquoi dans le
film écoutez
j'ai toujours eu l'idée comme gaston
defferre qui était un peu mon maître en
politique qui était d'ailleurs mon
monteur qui était comme un oncle en
vérité quand j'étais jeune député que
décentralisation qui était un objectif
qu'on voulait atteint pour la france
entière et est particulièrement
nécessaire en corse on constatait déjà à
l'époque à travers l'europe que la
plupart des régions insulaires d'europe
avait un statut particulier
c'était vrai pour madère c'était vrai
pour la sardaigne la sicile c'était vrai
pour la crète en grèce donc c'était
comme une espèce d'évidence
socioéconomiques ou historiques
politiques donc il y a eu la bonne
volonté politique il y a eu des avancées
institutionnelles concernant la corse ça
semble jamais suffisant c'est un peu ce
qu'on comprend aussi le le sujet est
complexe et on l'a un peu évoquée il ya
derrière tout ça quand même un enjeu
constitutionnel vous l'avez dit monsieur
le député vos références et l'article 73
l'article 74 de la constitution
c'est-à-dire des territoires d'outre-mer
sans parler du titre particulier de la
constitution qui est consacré à la
nouvelle calédonie g j'ai relu la
décision du conseil constitutionnel de
1991 qui pose des bornes assez assez
nette à certaines évolutions qui en a
validé d'autres par exemple l'idée de
l'enseignement du corse dans les écoles
à l'initiative de la de la collectivité
avec un contrat avec l'état ça a été
complètement validé par le conseil
constitutionnel s'est dit expressément
donc il ya eu des avancées et
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on regarde le code
général des collectivités territoriales
et les dispositions propres à la corse
il ya un statut particulier au regard
des autres collectivités la possibilité
de faire des propositions pour modifier
des règlements ou d où des lois et c'est
un vrai sujet
c'est quand on relit honnêtement quand
on relit avec un peu de recul et avec
peut-être évidemment parcours de préfet
l'article 1er est telle qu'ils étaient
proposées c'était une évidence
la rue montpensier ça ne pouvait pas
faire ça ne pouvait pas tenir ceci dit
au sein de la république
les discussions sont évidemment ouvertes
sont évidemment possibles pour pouvoir
où on met les lignes mais il faut faire
attention au point suivant qui est pas
technique est vraiment très très crucial
c'est que si on reste dans une logique
dit article 72 donnaient dans une
logique législatives si on bascule
article 73 articles 74 c'est à dire des
références comme la polynésie c'est une
réforme constitutionnelle qui est
nécessaire et la question qu'il faut se
poser notre pays est il prêt le
parlement de ce pays est-il prêt ou bien
le peuple par référendum à ratifier une
modification constitutionnelle qui
répond ce sens il faut bien voir qu'il
détient la clé de la réponse c'est pas
seulement les élus de l'île s'est pas
seulement le gouvernement c'est la clé
constitutionnel et permettez moi de dire
que ce n'est pas rien j'ajoute juste un
petit mot si vous le permettez vers la
fin du reportage le président du conseil
exécutif gilles simeoni dit quelque
chose lequel il faut être attentif ayez
le contexte on sent bien n'est quand
même pas très favorable de quoi
parle-t-on dans notre pays de
séparatisme
on a gardé les qu'il dit je pourrais pas
que la cour se soit l'otage de cela
aurait sur cette question
constitutionnelle ça vous concerne de
très près mandat mme astor il faut
passer par une réforme de la
constitution ou pas alors c'est un peu
compliqué de rejouer j'en ai donné de
travail en résumé on faire pour rebondir
sur ce que vous avez dit avant de
présenter le passage de monsieur jack ce
qui a toujours été un grand défenseur de
la corse est d'ailleurs il m'a accordé
une interview que j'ai publié à la fin
de mon livre où il dit des choses que je
vous encourage à les lire sur le fait
que la corse est une grande oubliée de
l'histoire il le maintien ça c'était
juste parce que je voulais lui rendre
hommage statut de fer statut jose
processus de matignon loin un autre si
vous voulez c'est vrai sans cesse les
lois ont accordé pas toujours plus de
pouvoir ont toujours reconnu la
spécificité de la corse et ça ça a
commencé avec de faire la loi defferre
1982 et quand vous lisez travaux
préparatoires c'est très fort et toute
la classe politique pas seulement la
socialisme aussi de droite disait cet
intérêt spécifique c'est une entité
spécifique il faut lui donner des
pouvoirs spéciaux vous êtes d'accord que
ça ne suffit pas non ça n'a jamais eu
freecom pour les noms les corps et si
vous voulez c'est vraiment vraiment la
juriste qui parle j'aurais été une
juriste parisienne honnête et un peu
rigoureux j'aurais dit la même chose un
moment donné on ne peut pas tout en dire
on reconnaît une architecture spécifique
en lui donne des compétences spécifiques
d'accord dans tous les statuts on donner
toujours plus de spécificité s'ils
voulaient organique matériel comme on
dit en droit mais sans jamais donner les
pouvoirs et ça c'est un problème général
de toute façon être des collectivités
territoriales en france qui n'ont pas
ciblé de pouvoir autonome c'est un
pouvoir qui est secondaire est résiduel
selon la constitution française sauf que
encore une fois dans les autres
territoires métropolitains et bien il
n'y a pas une majorité absolue et les
juristes que vous êtes considère que le
conseil constitutionnel a eu raison de
retoquer cette phrase avec le peuple
corse n'ont alors déjà il ya un nom
alors là la question est un peu
compliquée pour la constitution est ce
que je suis ce qui est non mais je vais
répondre en toute honnêteté
déjà il faut replacer tout ça toute
cette question qui est purement une
question de droit constitutionnel oui
bien sûr monsieur le préfet si demain la
corse et autonomie faut une révision de
la constitution c'est là vous pouvez et
6 et un statut d'autonomie
moi je m'inspire beaucoup des îles
étrangères la loi organique vient
compléter la constitution donc s'il ya
parisien constitution pour ne pas y
avoir de statut ça c'est évident mais si
vous voulez pour vous répondre par
rapport au peuple corse il ya une
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
qui est à l'image de ce qui est la
cinquième république très jacobine vous
parliez au début d'idéologie de
dogmatisme monsieur les acquaviva
rappeler que heureusement tous les
interlocuteurs n'était pas comme ça le
conseil constitutionnel à une
jurisprudence la tuque est très rigide
je dis juste que la notion de peuple
corse pour laquelle je suis favorable
mais là cette fois ci c'est la corse qui
parle juridiquement ça va être compliqué
tant que le conseil constitutionnel aura
la même posture donc pour cela et j'en
viens exactement à ce que dit monsieur
parfait monsieur préfet il faut réviser
la constitution je devais permet
d'indiquer pardon mais c'est important
que juridiquement il y avait beaucoup
d'évolution depuis la décision précitée
1991 c'est à dire en 91 effectivement
c'était un peu logique entre guillemets
que le conseil constitutionnel retoque
la proposition qui a été faite je
rappelle par un homme de droite qui
était josé rossi à l'époque mais ensuite
la constitution a été révisée et
reconnaît les populations je le cite
d'outre-mer
reconnaissant ses spécificités ses
intérêts spécifiques au sein la
république française ça pourrait laisser
savourer après l'élection les
nationalistes aux élections il ya eu
l'élection d'un président la république
plus jeune qui a fait du pacte jarron
girondins jouent leur appel les piller
sa campagne donc à cette évolution la
guide juridiquement permet peut-être
maintenant enfin d'aller vers des
négociations apaisées jacques follorou
moi j'ai plutôt le sentiment que
justement que cette spécificité elle a
au contraire elle a pas été reconnue
façon constante et que si ici un grief à
faire sur l'action de l'état
c'est plutôt son inconstance parce que
même après la décentralisation de faire
vous avez eu au contraire une politique
sécuritaire très forte avec l'envoi des
préfets bruce a pas de l'ancien
commissaire de nommer préfet dé la
sécurité ensuite vous avez charles
pasqua qui dit faut terroriser les
terroristes on est sur une très dure qui
ensuite il y aura la négociation
pourquoi
d'après vous mais je pense que c'est à
ce à quoi faire avec la corse non c'est
que je dis c'est que je pense que l'état
l'état n'est pas un monolithe ou avec
tout le monde qui pensent la même
manière ça s'adresse en effet à
aussi à l'histoire de l'état dans le
pays c'est ce qui fait que la
comparaison ne peut pas être automatique
systématique comme je l'entends sur
madère les autres îles de lamèque
tavannes et la sardaigne pourquoi parce
qu'en fait l'état italien n'a rien à
voir avec cet affront c'est sa
constitution son histoire et c'est la
france c'est l'état qui est construit
pays c'est louis ix ont cessé ça ramène
à des choses fondamentales qui
structurent non mais ça veut juste dire
qu'une il a peut-être besoin d'une
caractéristique du le deuxième point le
point en effet d'après après chacun se
prononce sur le seul qui sont de la
spécificité et moi ça c'est juste de
petits points ou là je sors à l'instant
de mon rôle de journaliste c'est à dire
que en effet la corse à bien des erreurs
et s'est dit d'ailleurs mot pour mot
dans dans le documentaire qui est quand
même très complet c'est que la corse à
bien des égards est un laboratoire
peut-être devrait être vu pour selon moi
comme un laboratoire politique d'art sur
l'organisation sur le lien entre le
citoyen et l'état le lien entre le
citoyen et sa représentation
démocratique donc sur le sur cette passe
de l'état et puis encore une fois je
pense que tout le monde s'accorde à dire
si on est pas de parti pris ce n'est pas
partisan de dire que sur ce problème qui
est complexe qui est ancien si c'était
qu'un problème de maintien de l'ordre il
serait déjà réglé donc on est sur un
prime politique une spécificité et que
pour répondre à cette question là j'ai
tout le monde a sa part de
responsabilité tout le monde à sa
vertu est aussi son voile a ses défauts
et comme à paris exactement et encore sa
responsabilité aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il faut la poser parce que c'est laid
c'est aussi aider de pouvoir politique
actuel aux manettes du pays depuis sept
ans les pays de la corse depuis sept ans
vous m'avez pas repris la sur le pays
sûr mais j'ai souri
fait plaisir et donc le chiisme est une
parenthèse dans la parenthèse marc bloch
le grand historien marc bloch il est
écrit après la seconde guerre mondiale
mais je ne comprends pas pourquoi on
peut pas être alsacien français et
européens chambre la parenthèse mais
pour revenir sur la responsabilité la
question de la responsabilité aussi des
élus nationalistes
autonomistes que vous voulez
ça fait sept ans qui sont au pouvoir
il ay à certain nombre de prérogatives
qui sont déjà entre leurs mains et il ya
des ja des champs entiers et on peut
aujourd'hui d'environ n'est pas dans
l'incantation disant ça qu'est ce qui a
été entrepris
sur l'énergie sur les transports soit
infrastructures sur les déchets par an
des déchets on dit ou dédié chez c'est
un problème majeur pour la corse et donc
il ne m'a saisie de l'actualité la
question la question qui se pose on peut
pas sans arrêt dire c'est la faute de
l'état c'est la faute de l'état c'est la
faute de l'état et je pense qu'il ya
aussi que autant l'état est victime de
ses propres de sa propre de ses propres
blocage manteau d'accord et je pense que
l'on peut aussi poser cette question là
du côté du pouvoir politique insulaire
parce qu'aujourd'hui est ce que dit
certaine manière on reste pas un peu
trop longtemps en tout cas on reste est
ce qu'on se focalise pas trop sur la
revendication sémantique sur les
revendications institutionnelles sur la
revendication symbolique
évidemment que je ne jouais pas ce
propos tout à fait puisque sept ans a
été trois élections territoriales il ya
une fusion entre une collectivité
territoriale du département qui s'est
opérée ces qui était un acte original et
unique en france continentale il y avait
un héritage de 100 millions d'euros
passif que nous avons eu au départ
puisqu'on parle de la gestion des
anciennes classes politique de la
question corse y compris que son lot ou
fermés un petit peu les yeux sur ce
qu'elle faisait parce qu'elle était un
petit peu le garant de l'ordre entre
guillemets républicain contre les
méchants autonomistes nationaliste que
nous représentions donc 100 millions
d'euros c'est un petit peu si je faisais
le sommet de l'île le monte cinto qu'un
sac de 50 kg sur les épaules plutôt que
de le faire sans sa croyez vous donc ça
c'est je pense que l'on a plutôt montré
une bonne gestion malgré cet héritage si
je regarde le plan pluriannuel
d'investissement des routes depuis 2010
est nous avons opéré 90% de ce plan donc
je crois qu'en termes de gestion
quotidienne sur un certain nombre de
choses nous avons prouvé que
économiquement et socialement et en
investissement nous avons tenu la barque
en l'état d'un héritage très compliqué
financièrement éthiquement et en
transparence ça c'est le premier point
quant à dire que changer la constitution
ceux-ci répliquent mance purement
symbolique je m'inscris totalement en
faux régler le problème de la fiscalité
sur les successions
qui est un problème endémique et
historique très important c'était
rendront 2027 est-ce que nous sommes
tous en ligne agen direct à cause d'une
histoire de non titrage des biens depuis
150 ans si nous avions appliqué l'impôt
sur succession normes et de france
continentale à n'importe quel citoyen
insulaire y compris ceux qui sont au rsa
ou qui sont sous le seuil de pauvreté il
sera obligé de vendre leurs biens pour
payer l'impôt tirant un acte de
dépossession massive on ne peut régler
ça qu'en tenant compte enfin de la
spécificité historique et politique de
ce dossier et par une règle spécifique à
travers statut d'autonomie autrement dit
je reviens à l'essentiel j'ai pris et ça
ça touche le patrimoine le logement
l'activité économique c'est à dire la
vie quotidienne des corses et tout le
monde est concerné quelle que soit
l'opinion politique en corse à y compris
le droit de gauche sont tous d'accord
d'ailleurs là-dessus c'est quand même
assez bizarre donc si je reviens sur le
sujet essentiel pour nous et arrêtons
d'avoir une vision culturelle
idéologique des choses nous ne l'avons
pas lorsque nous concerne par contre
nous avons rencontré des interlocuteurs
qui avait encore cette vision religieuse
jeu c'est très important puisque si nous
allons loupé encore un nouveau rendez
vous bien sûr qu'elle faisabilité
politique à trouver c'est pas simple
mais vous l'avez dit c'est un problème
politique sarkozy alors sa supposée
change ça suppose faire tomber les
masques ça suppose dire oui la règle
spécifique permettra de régler tel
domaine un spéculation tel domaine
insiste cathy succession tel domaine sur
les carburants tels domaines surcoût
d'insularité tel domaine sur une
fiscalité adaptée pour les entreprises
en état d'un surcoût d'un petit marché
et puis l'excusé moi de dire aussi que
nous sommes au coeur de la méditerranée
et malheureusement je l'entends pas un
grand teddy de l'étape parler de vision
méditerranéen de la france est alors je
tente juste et on va écouter l'extrait
dont je vous parlais dont vous parliez
michel delpech quel avenir pour les
relations entre paris et la corse les
choses peuvent-elles avancé sous ce
quinquennat écouter ce qu'on pense
gilles simeoni justement dans le
documentaire parce que je dis c'est que
aujourd'hui il ya une aspiration
profonde et ancienne en corse à la
reconnaissance de ce que nous sommes
collectivement et et nous volonté aussi
des corses de ce peuple de maîtriser
aussi largement que possible leur choix
essentiel c'est une inspiration qui est
profondément démocratique ça veut pas
dire l'autarcie ça veut dire la rupture
donc il faut trouver un chemin pour
construire ensemble au plan politique et
au plan juridique moi j'ai confiance et
la confiance qu'elle peut être ce chien
écoutez moi les mots que je mettrai en
avant ses dialogues république et le
tout dans un contexte apaisé apaisement
dialogue république et la place elle a
déjà essayé d'utiliser au maximum toutes
les dispositions de droit qui existe
déjà à exemple la possibilité de
proposer à l'état central des évolutions
législatives ça existe fall est proposé
c'est le parlement qui les vôtres a
après leur siège sis à une majorité
constitutionnelle pourquoi pas moi je ne
me prononce pas là-dessus mais je dis
dialogue un dialogue république
apaisement d'accords économiques
indépendance moi je vais pas me
prononcer là-dessus indépendance je ne
pense pas parce que moi je ressens au
fond de moi un attachement très fort de
la corse à la république et je pense que
ça serait un affaiblissement et pour
l'une et pour l'autre que de renoncer à
ce lien
était préfet j'ai reçu à trois reprises
à sa demande monsieur edmond simeoni
le papa du président du conseil exécutif
on a eu des discussions très très
agréable pour moi et je trouvais très
très fort de la part de cet homme de
venir me voir c'était à son initiative
de surcroît il soutenait le candidat à
l'élection présidentielle de l'époque et
j'ai jamais entendue dans sa voix la
moindre remise en cause de
l'appartenance de la corse à la
république pourquoi je dirais public
dialogue société apaisée vers
l'autonomie ou vers l'indépendance
mais ça c'est très honnêtement je
comprends même pas pour qu'on se pose la
question c'est à dire que la
revendication du hors jeu par l'argument
démocratique de celui qui a remporté
largement les élections n'est que
l'autonomie n'a jamais été
d'indépendance d'ailleurs les enquêtes
montrent les ans à priori bien sûr mais
les errements moi qui travaillant sur la
question nous plaidons bien pour une
autonomie qui ne peut être autre chose
que l'autonomie au sein d'une république
et je me permets de préciser que y
compris en italie ou dans les autres
pays de la constitution dit toujours en
général dans le fameux triptyque du
départ article 1 2 ou 3 la république
parce mithaniel et indivisible mais elle
reconnaît en son sein l'autonomie des
régions non ce n'est pas il faut arrêter
de mettre en avant si vous voulez c'est
en tout cas en droit constitutionnel en
droit constitutionnel cette
incompatibilité entre l'indivisibilité
l'autonomie des régions notamment portés
sont des îles
ceci n'est plus possible indivisibilité
ce n'est pas l'uniformité
peut-être économie et je me permets
juste pour répondre à monsieur le préfet
ce que je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous cette possibilité qu'elle a semblé
faire des propositions étaient
bienvenues le législateur n'a offert
mais pardonnez moi pour mes travaux j'ai
été voir chaque statistique et je vous
assure que c'est pas l'honneur du
gouvernement si je vous les donne mais
le premier ministre la plupart du temps
n'y répond pas donc à ce principe de
courtoisie de dialogue a plutôt été
opposé un principe de discourtoisie et
ça ça a été mis souvent en avant donc
c'est malheureusement une initiative qui
le situe coquille vide quoi en tout cas
la question de l'autonomie ou
l'indépendance se pose je vous avez
peut-être lu l'article de l'ops paru il
ya quelques jours la corse at elle les
moyens d'être indépendante jean guy
talamoni dit oui et jean martin
mondoloni dit non la question se pose
puis vous pouvez même aller lire sur la
pointe extrême de la revendication la
plus radicale à l'action violente fait
dire on voit bien que quand on compare
le l'époque du du haddad flnc unis très
fort et c'est encore contre content
quand on examine un peu ce phénomène de
violence et la façon dont il le dont la
stratégie du du flnc ses actions et c
est finalement ses limites on voit bien
que ça n'a pas grand chose à voir avec
en tout cas c'est très difficile c'est
différent
des irlandais des basques et que moi
j'ai toujours considéré analyser ce
nationalisme corse clandestins plutôt
comme un comme une stratégie de
harcèlement le but n'a jamais été de
battre l'état ça c'est ça me semble ça
me semble un fait donc on constate à
travers les actions et ensuite le
dialogue ait pu exister entre les
groupes clandestins et les et l'état
français après c'est clair qui est je
vous en prie non non à les hisser sur le
nom et le deuxième deuxième aspect c'est
sur le che sur le comment dire là je
reviens son droit d'inventaire c'est à
dire que les un moment donné le le
pouvoir le pouvoir
politique aujourd'hui en corse il a dit
des choses et n'a pas forcément des
livres est derrière
cet anglicisme mais en 2019 enfin 2019
vous avez l'émergence de deux collectifs
anti mafia en corse émanation de la du
corps social qui n'a rien d'un feu de
paille c'est vraiment le le fruit d'un
processus souterrain qu'une réaction du
corps social lui-même qui personne n'a
été le solliciter qui dit il y a un
problème profond au sein la société
corse qui est complètement nié à la fois
en tout cas par l'état et également par
le pouvoir politique insulaire et le
patron de la corse aujourd'hui qui a
tous les pouvoirs vous prêt je reviens
je puis dire là dessus mais gilles
simeoni à l'époque dit on va ouvrir un
grand débat et émettre des mots je suis
d'accord avec vous monsieur le député
c'est très important parce que si c'est
reconnaître un diagnostic et c'est de
dire à la collectivité donc dont on a la
charge je suis d'accord avec vous il ya
un problème est ce ce grand débat il a
été promis fin 2019 en 2022 il ne l'a
toujours pas eu lieu et la semaine
dernière à la faveur d'une nouvelle
manifestation d'un des comités en daim
des collectifs anti mafia gilles simeoni
a promis qu'il aurait lieu en octobre et
c'est pour eux et pour finir sur le fait
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une vraie question
sur la sur l'éventuelle autonomie
politique et économique en tout cas plus
grand acte et institutionnellement c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le patron de la corse n'a
jamais eu autant de pouvoir entre les
mains vous avez qu'une collectivité vous
avez beaucoup moins beaucoup moins de
députés pas de pardon 2 2 lui et puis
par ailleurs vous avez une manne
financière qui était encore plus
importante donc aujourd'hui géré la
responsabilité politique elle doit aussi
être accompagné de garde-fous d'une
rigueur et d'une capacité à protéger une
population avancer vers l'autonomie ça a
été les mots de gérald darmanin
lorsqu'il est venu sur l'île notamment
pour calmer les esprits lors de
violences après l'assassinât d'yvon
colonna en détention ce sera ma dernière
question jean félix acquaviva est ce que
paris encore une voix qui compte sur
l'île est ce que l'état français est
encore écouter ou est ce que comme
peut-être le dit jacques follorou des
groupes nations ont pris le pouvoir et
que l'état français n'a plus vraiment la
main sur la mafia ont pris le pouvoir
parce que ce n'est pas vrai tout comme
moi que tu existes et c'est une chose
comme les avions dénoncé publiquement et
compris en ce qui me concerne en tant
que parlementaire l'assemblée nationale
je crois pour la première fois
d'ailleurs pour un parlementaire on
demande à un rapport sur le délit
d'association mafieuse où se situe le
repenti en fait en comparant ce qui se
passe en sicile public - politiquement
c'était un engagement entre majorité ne
l'avons fait nous ferons encore comme
des actes de transparence pouvoir l'état
français qui a encore presque dit gilles
simeoni personnes nous met la main sur
l'épaule ni à moi même il ya gilles
simon n ya personne ça c'est un
engagement moral et politique et les
corses le savez c'est pour ça que nous
avons été élus
clairement et de ce point de vue là je
pense que même l'état le sait très bien
parce que l'état sait beaucoup de choses
en corse il a voulu faire comme il a
voulu un temps où un autre selon ses
envies politiques s'associent c'est la
réalité de cette proximité dit y'a pas
que les corses qui savait aussi l'état
qui s'est beaucoup beaucoup de choses et
qui ferait mieux de remplir ses missions
régaliennes comme il se doit des fois il
fait bien et souvent il y aurait
beaucoup de choses à dire c'est pour ça
que la politique pénale c'est quelque
chose qui doit être discutée entre élus
démocratie citoyens et forces
régaliennes succès lucas les compétences
l'autonomie c'est un point d'équilibré
essentielle historique et politique
quand on voit documentaire de
reconnaissance d'identité mais aussi de
levier d'action pour les corses aille
mieux comme l'on dit souvent pour nous
l'autonomie c'est pour le bonheur des
corps s'est pas portée à l'enfer vous y
croyez quand gérald a maintenant parlons
croissance et qu'on va vers l'est que
gérald darmanin l état se sont vus en
mêlée dans une gestion belliqueuse qui a
conduit à une explosion et au plus
mauvais moment pour eux au moment des
élections présidentielles parce que tous
ces questions là nous avions porté y
compris sur la mauvaise gestion du
rapprochement des prisonniers parce que
je rappelle quand même que l'assassinât
d'arles est un scandale d'état il y aura
une commission d'enquêté parlementaire
et nous on a pas finis dénouer les fils
de ce qui s'est passé je le dis quand
même malgré tout en passant puisque il y
aurait beaucoup de choses à découvrir
encore un autre mais aujourd'hui il faut
une discussion sérieuse et politique
avec un grand p encore une fois la
question de l'autonomie de la corse pose
la question de la république vis-à-vis
de sa capacité à entendre la démocratie
en tant de la bonne volonté de citoyens
et d'élus à entendre la capacité des
ouïes des règles spécifiques finalement
c'est pas de bercy ou d'ailleurs qui on
va pouvoir gérer le problème est
d'arrêter le dogmatisme idéologique et
chacun fera sa part du chemin nous avons
des responsabilités énormes et a vu la
société corse nous voulons bien les
assumer il ya aucun problème ne sont pas
là pour dire que c'était comme s'il
souhaitait ou communiquent mais par
contre il faut aussi que l'état arrête
d'être paternaliste et qu'il aille au
bout des choses avec nous autour de la
table nous sommes les gens de compromis
politique il faut que le compris
politique historique arrive et ce sera
la conclusion de cet échange de ce débat
merci infiniment à tous les quatre d'y
avoir participé merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis de nous avoir suivis
d'ailleurs tout au long de la saison
c'était la dernière de la saison se
retrouve quand même très très vite sur
public sénat bientôt
[Musique]